If you are the person who has
to champion cyber security and
get the company to a proactive
cyber security posture,
how do you make your case?
You're champion, it's your job to
be as well prepared as possible
given the cost benefits and
risk tolerance and so on.
What are the kind of
arguments you can make?
The easiest argument to make is
the bottom line argument, or
the economic argument that
it's going to save us money.
Of course security doesn't make money.
Security we would say it's a cost.
It doesn't bring money in, but
we could lose money because of that.
The economic argument we can make is,
the return on investment argument, or
the ROI argument.
Saying, if you don't do this,
we're going to lose $10 million.
If you do this, it's only going to cost
us 1 million and we save 5 million and
the losses we're going to suffer
are going to be reduced by half.
Then of course it's
an investment you make,
you're putting out one million but
you're saving five million.
So that is a pretty good return
on investment that we have.
So the economic argument of course
makes sense when you say that
by coming up with a budget
to put a control in place.
The cost of that we're going to
have Is going to result in savings
that are much greater than the cost.
Significant savings
greater than the cost, so
there is in a way a return
on the investment.
This is money we're going to lose
that we're not going to lose now.
And that's how our bottom line is
going to be in a better state.
Of course this does require that you
estimate the cost benefits that we're
talking about, and unfortunately,
it's pretty tricky.
Cost and benefits,
either you can exactly quantify them, so
that would be data driven,
or its perception.
So with perception it's sort of what
they perceived to be the risk, and what
they perceived the risk reduction, maybe
if we do A or B, or something like that.
Versus sort of actually knowing
those probabilities and
those impact numbers that
you are talking about.
So you're going to make an argument.
This is all fine and good, but
a lot of times it comes to perception,
and then people would say,
well, this is their opinion.
How do you know for sure?
Do you have some hard numbers?
And unfortunately, making this
argument is difficult because
a lot of times those hard
numbers are not easy to come by.